The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today, big
announcement.
Wednesday, no lecture.
Instead, Celebration Part 2.
And I'm going to say a
few words about it.
There is the room assignments.
I think they're the
same as last time.
If you miss the exam because
of illness, there will be a
make-up test on November
4th during class.
There's no weekly
quiz tomorrow.
I'll be available for office
hours 4:00 to 5:30 this
afternoon over here at 8-205.
So a couple of things.
I'm going to say few
words about the
quiz, the test, rather.
The celebration.
So the coverage is going to go
starting from the time of the
last celebration up through now,
but I think in view of
the fact that we started defects
on Friday, and my
thanks go to Professor
Demkowicz, who jumped in the
breach and lectured in my place
so that I could get
drawn into some of the
activities associated with the
visit of the President.
You will not have had the time
to go through your recitation
cycle on this new material.
So I'm not going to put anything
on defects on the
exam, all right?
So we'll go up through the end
of the unit on x-rays right up
through Bragg's Law,
indexing crystals.
So that starting Friday,
defects.
I'm not going to teach you
Friday, teach you Monday,
examine you Wednesday
and Tuesday.
Tomorrow I expect you're going
to have all sorts of
review-oriented activities
in your recitation.
So I don't want you torn between
trying to master a lot
of this new material, which is
quite different from what you
had in high school, and at the
same time trying to have a
catch up on capturing all that
material since the second
test.
So that having been said,
I'm going to remind you.
I'm going to basically say the
same thing I said before the
first celebration, but we
need to be reminded.
So what's the purpose
of the test?
The purpose of the test is to
give you a status report and
send you a message.
And there's really only two
answers here that we're
looking for.
You're either going to get a
smiley face or you're going to
get a frowny face.
That's all it's about.
I don't care whether it's
a 78 or a 75, but
hard 50 is a pass.
And if you're not mastering the
material, I intend to tell
you so and then invite you in so
that we can figure out how
to get you through.
Because everybody in this room
has the intellectual apparatus
to pass this class.
Some of you just are not
managing your time well and
you need to be told that.
So we will tell you that.
With one of these.
That's going to be
the message.
Go to the right room.
Bring five things with you:
Periodic Table, table of
constants, your age sheet,
calculator, and a pen,
something to write with.
You'll write on the
question paper.
No wireless devices.
Shut them off.
Don't even bring them.
What do you need your
cell phone for?
Don't need it during a test.
We're going to start at 11:05
promptly and stop at 11:55.
What's the strategy?
Read the entire paper.
Try every question.
You know this.
You get part marks if
you write something.
If you don't write
anything for the
question, you get a zero.
So try every question.
And start with the easy one.
The easy one for you may not
be the easy one for your
neighbor, but how do you know
what the easy one is?
I just put them down as they
came out of my mind.
I didn't put them down in
ascending order of difficulty,
chronological order,
topical order.
They're just--
they're there.
Leave tracks, tell us how you
got to the answer, Work
parametrically.
Don't start plugging in numbers
on the first line,
because if you make a
computational error on the
first line and drag it through
the entire derivation, you'll
make a mess of things.
You'll have wavelengths, size
of distance here to Chicago,
light moving at ten times
its normal speed
and stuff like that.
It's no good.
Focus on the question.
Don't just say, oh, it's
something to do with x-rays,
just give me some stuff that
you memorized about x-rays,
some stuff you wrote down in
your age sheet about x-rays.
If it's not about the question
that we asked,
I'll give you a zero.
I don't care how
much you write.
Write on the topic.
And refer to electronic
structure.
When you don't know what to say,
start talking to me about
electronic structure.
That's the theme of chemistry.
electronic structure
dictates behavior.
So talk to me about electronic
structure.
Do your own work.
And lastly, it says something
here, oh, good luck.
That's what it says.
Good luck.
So last day, Professor
Demkowicz
got to the line defects.
He was talking to us about line
defects and how they have
an impact on behavior.
So I wanted to pick up
the treatment there.
So what's the whole issue
behind line defects?
Well, what line defects do is
they explain this anomalous
behavior where the measured
value of yield strength--
so I'm going to write
sigma y; sigma is
the symbol for strength.
the yield strength as measured
is on the order of only about
1/10 of the theoretical value.
It's only about 1/10 of the
theoretical value for the
yield strength.
You might, say, wait a minute.
How do you get that
theoretical value?
You can calculate this.
Not too badly.
If I take a look at a system of
atoms, and this could be a
metallic crystal, you could
argue that there are metallic
bonds between all of these
atoms. And if what I wanted to
do to shear something--
so this is the yield strength
for shear--
if I wanted to shear the top
plane of atoms versus the
bottom plane of atoms, can
you see that to a first
approximation, the energy
required would be the energy
to break each one
of these bonds?
Because I have to break the bond
to release the plane and
then move it.
So if you make an estimation
on the
basis of bond strength--
so you take individual bond
strength times bond density or
bond concentration.
When I say density, I don't
necessarily mean
mass per unit volume.
I could mean bonds
per unit area.
You saw your homework
questions.
How many atoms per
unit length?
And we said what's the
linear density?
And some people were saying,
but density is
mass per unit volume.
No, I'm counting atoms
per unit length.
Open your mind, OK?
So bond strength, what's
bond density?
That's atoms per unit area.
So we can calculate this
and we're way off.
We're way off by about
a factor of 10.
So it was the dislocation
that allowed us to
explain why this happens.
And it was the work of two
scientists, one by the name of
Orowan in Hungary and
Taylor in the UK.
Orowan, after World War II,
went to the UK and then
ultimately came to MIT.
And he spent most of this later
part of his career here
in the Mechanical Engineering
Department,
from which he retired.
And actually, he's too modest
to say it, but Professor
Demkowicz, his PhD was for
Professor Argon, and Professor
Argon was one of Orowan's
students.
So this is direct lineage.
This is all very clear, so he
was the appropriate person to
introduce dislocations.
So what did Orowan do?
Orowan came up with this idea
of an interruption.
And how did he get it?
It shows how to look
around and, in
the world, see analogies.
Now, we didn't have the powerful
electron microscopes
then that we have today.
This was in the 1930s, so people
didn't even agree on an
atomic view of things.
So people were thinking,
thinking, thinking.
So this is the dislocation.
You can see.
Here, we have three rows of
atoms, now there's two rows of
atoms. The middle
row stops there.
And I'll show you what the
consequence of that is in
terms of being able to shear the
crystal of lower values of
applied stress.
So that's the dislocation.
You can see here.
If you break this bond and then
propagate that through,
you don't have to
shear them all.
You break them one at a time.
So Orowan came home one day in
Budapest, and the cleaning
woman was moving the runner on a
hallway, the story goes, and
she was about to move
the runner.
And Orowan came up the stairs
and offered to help her, and
she told him, get
out of the way.
Academic.
And what she did, instead of
pulling the rug, she did what
we see in the cartoon here.
She put a little kink in the
rug, snapped her foot and
propagated the kink and moved
the rug a half a foot down the
hallway with minimal energy.
Instead of having to pull the
rug with it's coefficient of
fraction over three, four
meters, all she had to do was
come up with enough energy
to make the kink and
then stamp the foot.
This person's really doing
it the hard way.
I don't know.
This guy must have
taken classes in
chemistry or something.
But see, all you've
got to do--
once you get that kind
you just push
and it'll go by itself.
So Orowan said could this be a
metaphor for what's going on
at the atomic level?
And that's where it came up
with this idea of the
dislocation.
So there we have it.
So where do we find
the dislocations?
Where do we find them?
So what is it?
The dislocation--
I keep talking about
it, what is it?
The dislocation, this is, if you
like, it's a line defect.
It's a line defect formed by
misregistry of atoms. And with
the misregistry, that leads to
a reduction in bond density.
And that broken bond is like the
hole, if you like, in the
valence band.
It can propagate very easily.
We're going to learn a little
bit later in the lecture where
we find dislocations and
how they contribute.
But I want you to hold that
in near-term memory.
OK.
So we're going down
the list of the
different types of defects.
Oh here, I found this off a
coffee table book that's
indicating--
I think this is a
crummy analogy.
It shows this caterpillar
moving by.
Instead of moving all of its
legs, it causes this thing--
I think this is a bad analogy.
Just look down here.
You see, you breaking this.
And once you break this, you
just keep moving it along.
Propagate the single broken bond
instead of breaking them
all at once.
I don't think the caterpillar
moves that way, anyway.
It's cute, but it's wrong.
This is a dislocation.
I don't think it has anything
to do with mechanical
behavior, but it's
a misregistry.
So you can--
these guys, they write the books
and they come up with
this stuff and you study
it, and you're
going, I don't get it.
You know what?
You shouldn't get it.
Because this is crummy.
It doesn't make any sense.
How does that impact the yield
stress of the corn?
Someday you could
write a book.
Better one than this.
All right, so now we're
going to go to
two-dimensional defects.
Let's go to two-dimensional
defects.
So two-dimensional defects,
there's a couple types.
The dislocation is
one dimensional.
Two-dimensional defects.
There's two types.
One is the free surface.
We're going to call the free
surface a defect, and I'll
explain why in a second.
And then internal surfaces.
Internal--
I'm going to use surface in
quotation marks-- they're
interfaces.
And there's different
types of them, OK?
An interface.
There's an interface
inside the thing.
So what's the physics here?
Surfaces are high-energy
regions.
Why?
Because when you're inside
the crystal, you have the
prescribed number of
nearest neighbors.
Let's say you're in
an FCC crystal.
You're an aluminum atom.
So you're an aluminum atom
and you've got 12 nearest
neighbors because you're
FCC, except if
you're at the free surface.
If you're an aluminum atom at
the free surface you don't
have 12 nearest neighbors.
Because if I look down I've got
aluminum atoms all over.
If I look up, I've
got nothing.
So axiomatically, I've got a
different number of bonds.
Why do we form bonds?
We form bonds in order
to lower the
energy of the system.
But axiomatically, the ones at
the top can't form the same
number of bonds, so they
are not in the
same low energy state.
So once you get the connection
between lower number of bonds,
higher energy state, then any
place, free surface, internal
surface, is going to be
relatively high energy.
Relatively higher energy than
atoms in the matrix.
Matrix.
What do I mean by matrix?
In the middle of a crystal.
In the matrix, OK?
So that means that it's not
quite as tightly bound, so the
consequence of this is if
they're high-energy regions,
so high-energy implies
higher reactivity.
And that can be good
or it can be bad.
It can be good if you're trying
to design a catalyst.
And it can be bad in the
case of corrosion.
Where do you think
corrosion occurs?
Not deep inside the crystal.
It occurs at the surface along
the grain boundary.
So here's a cartoon that
shows different
regions within the crystal.
And Professor Demkowicz
showed you on Friday--
and I'll cut to the thing
in a second, the Atomix.
but here we see atoms. So this
is a simple cubic, this is
simple cubic, this
is simple cubic.
But when they meet they
don't line up.
They don't line up because
this formed from
solidification from the melt.
So there might have
been a seed here
and it grows outward.
A seed here and it
grows outward.
And when they grow outward they
impinge, but they're not
all growing with the
same orientation.
You already know what
the planes are.
And they could even be the
same plane, but they're
starting from a different
point.
So there's this misregistry
here.
But it's not a misregistry
like the dislocation.
It's a two dimensional
misregistry.
Actually, let's cut to
the document camera.
Dave, could we do that please?
OK, so here's Atomix.
This was, as explained, an
object of art made by Francois
Dallegret in Quebec
in the '60s.
So it's kinetic.
It's supposed to be after
the artist, see?
You know, you, too.
You pick it up on a coffee
table, you put it down, now
you have become the artist.
You become the artist.
Postmodernism.
After the death of
the artist. See?
I'm an artist. Look.
I'm an artist. One
of my best works.
So a couple of my professors at
the University of Toronto
were at a cocktail party one
night and they saw this thing
on a table.
Must've been a wild party
because they kept looking at
this thing.
Finally decided to write
a paper about it.
And as Professor Demkowicz said,
I bet Francois Dallegret
sold more of these to professors
of material science
than he sold to art
collectors.
So it's 200 ball bearings
strategically placed between
two plates of plexiglass.
And as he pointed out on
Friday, you can't get
everything to go away in terms
of dislocations, but now you
can see misregistry--
pardon me, vacancies here.
Here's a stacking
fault and so on.
And now here you see
grain boundaries.
There's the free surface.
Here's the vapor phase.
Everything.
We're having a lot
of fun, here.
So we can look at it again.
We can change.
We'll try to anneal it.
So how do we anneal it?
You put it in an oven
and you eat it.
This is the mechanical
equivalent of annealing.
I'm tapping it, for those
of you in the back.
Now, I'm going to put it down
and you see I have a much more
refined structure.
So now you can see
a large section
here of a single crystal.
Each one of these is
called a grain.
A grain is a zone
that is a single
crystal with some defects.
You can see the vacancies.
And then look at the grain
boundary here.
See this is a nice crystal,
this is a nice crystal.
So one grain, two grains, and
there's the grain boundary
where these don't line
up with those.
Because they started from a
different angle so they can't
impinge and blend.
There's grain boundaries here,
here, here, and there's
beautiful stuff.
You can see dislocations.
Everything.
And I know he showed you at the
end the Bragg bubble wrap.
And you could see--
[SOUND EFFECT]
PROFESSOR: --dislocations
zipping.
When people were trying to
compress the bubble wrap, the
way the bubble wrap was
compressing the bubbles didn't
all get flat.
The bubbled glided over one
another, and the dislocations
relieved the stress.
See what I'm telling you here?
What I'm telling you here is
something that you don't get
in a Gen Chem class
anywhere else.
If I told you about the
chemical origins of
reactivity, you'd go, yeah,
that's chemistry.
But what are we talking
about here?
We're talking about the
chemical origins
of mechanical behavior.
Now that's different.
The chemical origins
of mechanical
behavior: only in 3.091.
And why shouldn't we?
Because at the end, everything
is chemistry.
Everything is chemistry.
The rest is stamp collecting.
So the grain--
make sure we know where
the grain is.
The grain is like, I want
to call single crystal.
The grain is like a
single crystal.
And the grains are separated
by grain boundaries.
So by managing grain boundaries,
control of grain
boundaries, or if you like,
management a grain boundaries,
this has an impact on mechanical
properties.
This is called grain boundary
engineering.
How we control mechanical
properties.
Grain boundary engineering.
So for example, if we
want high strength--
and I just told you that the
dislocations will allow the
atoms to glide.
Can you see that if the
dislocation is present in this
large grain on the bottom here
and the dislocation, just as
in the bubble wrap movie, is
zipping across, what happens
when it gets to the
grain boundary?
The misregistry of
atoms stops that
dislocation dead in its tracks.
So if I want high strength, do I
want a large number of grain
boundaries per unit area?
Or a small number of grain
boundaries per unit area if my
goal is to stop the
dislocations?
I want a high number.
High strength means fine
grain structure.
Fine grained means
small grain size.
Fine grain structure.
You can think of it
as like a river.
You know, you're running,
running, running-- all of a
sudden, you stop because you've
got to ford the river.
On the other hand, if you
want high ductility--
why would you want ductility?
For example, you want to make
a beverage container.
How do you make a beverage
container?
Not by casting.
You take a sheet of aluminum and
you punch it and you cause
it to deep draw.
That's atoms sliding
over atoms.
So do I want to facilitate that
process or do I want to
impede the process?
Well, to facilitate the process,
I want to make it as
easy as possible for
those atoms to
glide over one another.
So high ductility means coarse
grain structure.
Coarse grain means
large, if you
like, large grain diameter.
Fine grain structure means
small diameter.
So there we go.
That's the beginning.
And there's a lot more to it,
but I just wanted you to see
that there is something.
And David, may we cut back
to the slides, please?
OK, I think the next
one shows.
All right, so this is a--
oh, we don't want to hear that.
Whoops!
Well, I've got music embedded
in this one.
This is Philip Glass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: Because we're going
to talk about glasses later.
Koyaanisqatsi.
It's beautiful.
Can you feel the bass?
There's the subwoofer
right here.
You stand right here.
It's like a message.
Low frequency, of course.
All right, so here's this.
But this is a piece of copper.
Now, this was the advent
of modern materials
characterization when Sorby, in
the late 1800s, figured out
that if you polish the piece
of metal supersmooth--
that's good, huh?
Maybe we better turn
the volume down.
I can't compete with these.
There's more of them than me.
I can't compete.
That's called the mute button.
[MUSIC ENDS]
PROFESSOR: So what did he do?
He polished the copper and
then he etched it.
And what happens with
an acid etch?
It will etch at different rates
because the different
grains have different
atom densities.
You see, if I take a piece of
metal and I polish it super,
super bright and I shine a light
on it and look at it in
a microscope, what am
I going to see?
I'm going to see my
eyeball, right?
I'll blind myself.
So the key was to etch.
And then when you etch,
you differentiate
the different grains.
So that's what you're looking
at-- the grain boundaries.
And this is now the same thing,
only under a field ion
microscope.
This is a bicrystal
of tungsten.
It's hard to see, but
this is all one.
This looks like a lolly
pattern, doesn't it?
You can see the symmetry here.
I don't know if you can
see right here.
There's a line, sort
of v-shaped here.
And that's the second crystal.
So there's one crystal here,
a second crystal here.
So this two-dimensional defect
is now characterized.
And we'll get to that later.
OK.
So now we want to do
three-dimensional defects.
What are the three-dimensional
defects?
Three-dimensional defects
are important.
And they have beneficial
and they have harmful
consequences.
Three-dimensional defects.
The dominant mechanism
here is coalescence.
So three-dimensional defects
formed by coalescence.
And you can coalesce
two things.
You can coalesce voids,
or you can coalesce--
actually, you can coalesce void,
and you can coalesce--
I'm going to use Democritus
talk here.
You can coalesce void, or
you can coalesce being.
What do I mean by that?
Well, void, this could
be a vacancy cluster.
So if you have a large number
of vacancies coalescing,
you'll actually end up
with a hole, a blow
hole inside the material.
And as you can imagine,
that has the
mechanical strength of nothing.
That's bad.
And being?
This could be impurity
clusters.
And there's two types of
impurities, as we've learned.
There are good impurities, such
as dopants, and there are
bad impurities such
as contaminants.
And what can they do
to the mechanical
properties if they are bad?
So what I like to say is
impurity clusters--
so we've got, for example,
there are good
ones that are managed.
The ones that are managed can
be used to our advantage.
So I'm going to say the managed
ones get a smiley
face, and the ones that
are uncontrolled--
I'll give you a vivid
example of that at
the end of the lecture.
Uncontrolled, they get a frowny
face, and they can lead
to major disasters.
So for example, you're really
talking about clusters that
exsolve as a separate phase.
So these things exist
as a separate phase.
So they're no longer
dissolved.
And these precipitates, some of
these impurity clusters, if
they're managed, we can call
them precipitates.
i'll give you an example
of precipitates.
Some of you might be going home
at some point in the not
too distant future, maybe
for Thanksgiving.
And if you're flying on an
airplane, the airplane is made
of an aluminum alloy.
Aluminum copper.
And one of the precipitates that
you can form is various
copper-aluminum compounds.
And these form precipitates
that the volume of
copper-aluminum 2 is greater
than the volume of the
constituents.
So if you take a copper atom and
two aluminum atoms in the
lattice and they react to form
copper-aluminum 2, there's a
volume increase.
And so that works to give
you constituents.
Isn't that great?
I left you in suspense there
as to rest of the word.
So what happens?
This works a little bit the way
carbon does in iron, where
carbon atom is bigger than the
interstitial void space in
iron, and that force fit leads
to a strengthening.
This leads to a strengthening,
oK?
So that's good.
So this is called precipitation
hardening.
I'm just going write
precipitation pptn,
precipitation hardening.
Very important in metallurgy.
Whereas carbon in iron is called
solution hardening.
Because it doesn't exist
as a separate phase.
The carbon atom is sitting on an
interstitial site so it's a
force fit, but it's still within
the lattice, whereas
the copper-aluminum actually
exists as a precipitate
outside the lattice.
So there we go.
In order to give you a little
bit more, I said we're going
to talk about the
chemical origins
of mechanical behavior.
And I want to show you
how this all leads to
strengthening, strengthening
in terms of the yield.
So let's talk about deformation
and the
relationship to chemistry.
There's two types
of deformation.
And this really accounts for
the importance of metals in
the history of man.
Why?
Because they have this
unique property.
Until the modern era, when
we discovered plastics.
But until modern era, metals
are deformable.
They can deform without
breaking.
That's what made them so
desirable as materials of
construction.
So I'm going to talk
about deformation,
how we deform them.
So really, metallurgy
consists of--
really, there's two major
divisions of metallurgy.
The first part is chemical,
chemical metallurgy, and
that's called dirt to metal.
That's the conversion.
This is the intensive
chemistry.
And then the second part is
called physical metallurgy,
which is what I'm going
to talk about next.
Physical, which is
change of shape.
That relies on the ductility.
So deformation.
There's two types
of deformation.
The first one is called
elastic deformation.
And it is reversible.
So it is strain only
under stress.
Or if you like, displacement
only under applied force.
So this is Hooke's Law.
Hooke's Law applies.
So let's take a look.
I'm going to draw a
little curve here.
You've seen this before.
I'm going to draw one of
these energy curves.
So this is interatomic
separation, which we might use
the lower case r.
And this is the potential energy
that's stored between
two atoms. Remember, when
they're far apart, they want
to attract.
When they get too close
together, their electronic
shells repel.
So we've got--
time for colored chalk--
we have the attractive
component,
which looks like this.
And then we have the repulsive
component, which looks
something like this.
And then we put the two of them
together, and I think we
did this for ions, but there's
an analogous one for other
materials, and so you add the
two of these, and you
eventually end up like this,
where this is r naught.
r naught, the optimum
separation.
Here's attraction, this
is repulsion,
et cetera, et cetera.
So this is e minimum.
We've seen all of that before.
Now what's this have to do
with mechanical behavior?
Well, I'll take it just
a little bit farther.
And so I'm going to take
the derivative of that
and look at the force.
All right, so now I'm going
to take the first
derivative of that.
So this is going to be force,
which is equal to de dr. Force
is the derivative of energy.
And what do I find?
Well, look.
If I take this derivative,
below r equals r naught.
I've got a negative slope.
Above r equals r naught--
I have a positive slope.
And at r equals r naught,
zero slope.
So I'm want to put
that down here.
So it's zero right at r equals r
naught, and above r equals r
naught it's positive,
and below r equals
r naught it's negative.
Not to scale.
But one thing is certain.
It is positive above r equals
r naught, negative below r
equals r naught, and to a first
approximation, I can
linearize about r equals
r naught, Or Emin.
So what's the real shape
of this thing?
You could use a Taylor
series if you want.
And just take the first-- what's
the first term of a
Taylor series?
Constant.
Second term, linear.
Third term is squared,
da, da, da, da.
So neglect higher order terms.
You get a straight line.
And what does this mean?
It means that if I try to
disturb the atoms from one
another and move them away
from their rest position,
there's a force that pulls them
back, and the force is
proportional to the
displacement.
If I move the atoms farther
apart by a distance r1, I get
a certain force.
If I move them apart by r2--
2 times r1--
I get twice the force.
It's linear.
Now let's go over here.
Now let's draw another
analogy.
So here I've got something
that's pegged.
And now I'm going to put a
spring onto this secure wall.
So here's my spring, and
I'm going to hang
a mass on the spring.
Now I'm going to bring this
into Hooke's Law.
I'm going to show you that what
you know to be Hooke's
Law is a direct consequence
of this.
The atomic origin.
So what's the force on this?
There's a force on this, and
that's equal to product of the
mass times the gravitational
constant.
And if there were no mass,
this spring would be
compressed and it might
be sitting here.
I will call this x naught.
And now that I put the
spring here I'll
measures, say, this point.
And this point here is
now at some value x.
So this is the displacement,
isn't it?
This is the delta x.
So Hooke's Law is simply f
equals k delta x, isn't it?
If I double the delta x,
requires double the force.
Well, that's this.
This analogy goes right down.
And if I remove the mass it
springs back, which is what I
meant when I said
it's reversible.
This is not permanent.
No stress, no strain.
Strain is the deformation.
No deformation, no force.
If I put a force, non-zero
force, non-zero deformation.
By the way, Hooke--
little bit of culture--
Hooke announced Hooke's
Law in 1676.
Here's how Hooke's Law
was first published.
It's an anagram and
it's in Latin.
And it was in a book entitled A
Decimate of the Centesms of
the Inventions I Intend to
Reveal, which is English for,
This is a Tenth of the Hundreds
of the Inventions I
Intend to Reveal.
He did not suffer from an
overabundance of modesty.
Actually, Hooke and
Newton sparred.
They hated each other's guts.
They fought bitterly.
Two giant egos.
Anyway, so here's the thing.
So in 1679 he published a book
called De Restitutiva.
On The Spring.
Very presumptuous.
And here it is in its unraveled,
ut tensio, sic vis.
As the extension,
so the force.
Nice, huh?
This is u.
That's why the u, but
it's really v.
Vis.
We get the English word
vim from this.
This is the accusative
form of vis.
The Romans didn't care
between the u and v.
In fact, if you go on the steps
of 77 and you come up,
it says Massachusetts Institute
of Technology, you
ever notice this?
Yeah.
I always thought that
that's because the
Romans, they couldn't--
no.
And I thought, well, maybe it's
because it's hard to make
a u, but then it says
Institute of--
I figure if you can make one of
these, you should be able
to make one of these.
So if you can tell me why they
do it that way, I might be
able to find another Periodic
Table beach towel.
So that's another thing.
All right.
So that's the elastic
deformation.
And now we want to look at the
other type of deformation, and
that's called plastic
deformation.
And that's permanent.
It's a permanent shape change.
So let's get that up here.
Permanent shape change.
And this requires ductility.
Because otherwise you'll
have fracture.
If you take something that has
no ductility and you apply a
super critical force, you
just crack everything.
So ductility allows
for the atoms to
glide over one another.
So what is the mechanism?
The mechanism for plastic
deformation?
Plastic deformation in crystals,
we're talking about
here, not liquids.
It's called slip.
Atom's slip over one another.
So time for one more cartoon.
So I'm going to say, well,
what happens if I
start again with this?
I'm going to put a thin wire,
a thin wire of metal.
Make it an FCC metal, let's say
it's copper, and I'm going
to put a mass here--
a honking big mass--
it's going to give me a force,
and the force is great enough
that it is actually going to
cause the wire to elongate.
That is permanent
shape change.
So what's going on?
Well, let's take this
and blow it up.
When we blow it up, we have
what's on the screen.
We have grains of
different size.
And I'm just going to
show atomic planes.
And that's why we have
grains, right?
Because the atomic planes
don't line up.
There's a misregistry
along here.
So now I want to go down
to the atomic level.
So now I'm going to take
this and blow it up.
And what do I see here?
I see atoms like so.
I'm going to use that
hard-sphere,
close-packed model.
So here's the force.
The force is vertical, agreed?
We've got the mass and it's
pulling straight down
according to gravity.
So what's going on at the
atomic dimension?
Because ultimately, this is
what we're working with.
So what happens?
One possibility, and don't
laugh-- this was actually
suggested--
when you cause extension in this
manner, you actually take
some of these and you
can turn them into
elongated atoms. No, no.
That's no good.
What in fact happens is slip.
So the force-- in fact, let
me be more specific--
the applied force is resolved
at atomic level.
So what happens is that the
atoms slip over one another
because they can slip along the
planes that have the least
bonding between them, right?
The chain is as strong
as its weakest link.
So what will happen here is that
in order to affect the
elongation, these will move
relative to one another along
this slip plane.
This is resolved at the atomic
level along slip planes.
I'll write that larger
for the people way,
way up in the back.
I haven't forgotten about you.
And what's the slip plane?
How do I determine which
is the slip plane?
The slip plane it's going to be
the plane that's strongest
because it retains
its integrity.
So which plane will
be the strongest?
The one with the most bonds.
And which plane has
the most bonds?
The plane with the highest
number of atoms per unit area.
And that's why we study
this stuff.
Because now we know,
in an FCC crystal,
which plane will slide.
So in FCC, the high-intensity
plane is 1 1 1.
So the 1 1 1 planes do the
sliding one over another.
And they'll zigzag the way you
saw in the bubble wrap movie.
They'll zigzag down, across,
across, across, But from a
distance, it appears as the
thing is elongating.
But at the atomic level, it's
zigzagging along the
close-packed planes.
Now I'm in a close-packed
plane.
By the way, if I have the
highest density in the plane
of the floor, can you understand
that orthogonal to
the plane on the floor, I must
have the weakest density?
All right, now I'm
in the plane.
Which direction in the plane?
Any direction?
I'm going to push, I'm going
to push some pasta.
I'm going to push uncooked
pasta or cooked pasta?
Do you want to push on a rope?
Do you want to push
on a broom handle?
The stiff.
So how do I determine, within
the plane, which direction is
the stiffest direction?
The one with the most atoms,
which is the close-packed
direction when I'm
in the plane.
So if I'm in the 1 1 1 plane,
which direction?
The 0 1 1 direction.
So this is direct line of
sight from the original
crystallography.
So that's how we get the slip.
And in BCC the highest density
plane is 0 1 1 and so on.
And the close-packed plane
simply means 1 1 1, because
FCC is the closest-packed
structure, so that's a
close-packed plane.
Otherwise, they're planes
of highest density.
It's a trivial--
forget the last column--
it's pedantry.
Forget it.
I'm sorry I have it up there.
So this is the slip system.
So the slip system is
the combination of
close-packed plane--
or closest-packed plane--
close-packed plane and the
close-packed direction.
They all have close-packed
directions because we've got
atoms touching.
Close-packed direction.
That's how it deforms. And then
if I get a dislocation in
a close-packed plane, voom!
Away they go.
1/10 of the applied sheer
stress theoretical.
So if you want to get it down
to a simple phrase, you can
say, what causes slip?
Atoms slip, dislocations
glide.
But please don't think for
one minute-- listen to me
carefully-- a lot of students
come away from this and they
say, oh, I know why we
have deformation.
Because of dislocations.
No, no, no, no.
Atoms will slip no
matter what.
It's just that you're going to
pay a lot more to cause the
deformation.
The dislocations allow you to
have slip at lower cost.
Yeah, this is good.
And I think we're probably at
the point where I can show you
the enormous consequences of
a three-dimensional defect.
Why did the Titanic sink?
It's a story of
three-dimensional defects and
human greed.
So this Tim Fecke at the
National Institutes of
Standards and Technology with
an optical microscope and a
rivet from the Titanic.
And what I'm going to show
you in the rivet is a
three-dimensional defect that
took the boat down.
So this is the microstructure
and what they're doing is
they're showing you a blow up of
this section of the rivet.
Now, the rivet is
made of steel.
Before I can explain to you
what's going on there, I have
to show you--
[MUSIC STARTS]
PROFESSOR: Oh, shut up.
[MUSIC ENDS]
PROFESSOR: All right, so this
is how they made steel.
Imagine this area the front of
10-250 as an open-hearth
furnace, and I'm up to about
my knees in liquid iron.
And on top of the liquid iron
is a slag made of silica,
calcia, and alumina.
It's the stuff when it
solidifies it makes something
not too different from
window glass.
But we use it for refining to
get some of the impurities out
of the metal.
And those impurities go up
into the slag phase.
And to keep this thing it
about 1,300 degrees
Centigrade, you've
got burners.
Two.
One at each end like dragons--
[SOUND EFFECT]
PROFESSOR: --blowing flame into
here for about 12 hours.
12 hours.
And that's what it took
to make a heat of
steel back in 1910.
This was made in Ireland, which
was, at that time, part
of the United Kingdom.
So on that day that they made
the heat of steel that
ultimately was shaped into
rivets, evidently somebody
became greedy, and instead of
waiting long enough for the
slag to phase separate and form
a film on the surface of
the metals, much like oil and
water don't mix, but you can
shake them up in your salad
dressing application tool
device and then pour
it on quickly.
But if you let it sit
they phase separate.
Well, somebody didn't allow
this to phase separate.
They were told, pour
the heat anyways.
So now you have globs of what
is the precursor to silicate
glass in the metal.
And now we take the metal and we
cut it into little billets
and the billets are extruded
to form rivets.
And then the rivets look
like this, where
you have glass stringers.
Three-dimensional defects,
impurity clusters,
uncontrolled.
What are the mechanical
properties of steel?
Strong.
Ductile.
Tough.
What does toughness mean?
Impactability.
When you say someone is tough,
it means they know how to take
a hit, whereas hardness means it
takes enormous strength to
cause deformation.
They're very different.
You know?
You say someone is tough,
you mean one thing.
You say they're strong,
it's different.
You can be strong and
yet not tough.
You can be strong and brittle,
so you can't take a hit.
I know a lot of people
like that.
That can't take a hit.
Anyway, so enough about
the people.
So here are the stringers.
So what happened?
What do you think
the mechanical
strength of this is?
If you have an impact like
so, instead of having the
toughness to absorb the impact,
these things broke.
This is like perforations on
a sheet of postage stamps.
And so these rivets
were on the hull.
And when the ship hit the
iceberg, what should have
happened is there should have
an a small hole, the water
would've taken, who knows, a
day or two to fill up, and
there was plenty of time
to get rescue vessels.
Instead, these rivets were
brittle, thanks to this.
And so they just unzipped.
Just pop, pop, pop, pop,
pop, pop, pop.
Opened up a giant hole and
then took on the water.
Now, did nobody check?
Along the way, no inspection
of the steel?
Nobody looked?
The guys that we're doing the
riveting, they must have known
the rivets were acting
strange.
They must have broken a lot of
them just putting them in.
But hey, it's not my job.
Not my job.
No testing anywhere
along the way.
What's shocking is
not human greed.
That's as old as humanity.
What's shocking is there
was no checks.
So we have a different way to
make vessels like this today.
But that's the story,
right there.